لا يوجد شيء مثل الخروج من
السيارة عندما يتم ترشيحك لجائزة الأوسكار
التي تشبه اللحظة قبل الأخيرة
في مهنة شخص ما أو
عندما تخطو إلى
لحظة رفيعة المستوى للغاية ، أردت النساء اللواتي
كنت أعمل معها  لأشعر بالرضا عن
[الموسيقى]
ميشيل أوباما التي كانت على الأرجح واحدة
من أكثر اللحظات التي اكتشفتها في
حياتي لأنني جئت لبناء مسيرتي المهنية
في وقت تلك الإدارة حيث
كان من المفيد جدًا إنشاء
شركة أمريكية تصنع الملابس الأمريكية
تلبيس السيدة الأولى كنت
هكذا هو الحلم الأمريكي الذي بعت سيارتي
وانتقلت إلى نيويورك وانتقلت إلى
خزانة وحصلت على تدريب داخلي مع
امرأة تدعى ديبوراه شاوني
وظفتني بدوام كامل بعد سبعة أيام
وأنا  كنت في حقيبتي السكنية الأخيرة ، لذا
الحمد لله فعلت ذلك ، ثم
بدأت العمل مع نيكولا فورمان
كيني الذي كان قد بدأ لتوه مع gaagaa
في ذلك الوقت ولذا فقد ساعدت
لسنوات عديدة ولم أذهب إلى المدرسة من
أجل صنع  الملابس ولكني أعتقد أن
التصميم كان تعليميًا رئيسيًا بالنسبة لي ،
كل صديقاتي هن من النساء اللواتي
تعرضن للمخاطر وحياتهن الخاصة لم
يقل أحد منهم هذه فكرة سيئة
غاغا صديقاتي المقربات من المنزل
قال كل شخص حسنًا ، شكرًا  أنت
كثيرًا لتظهر في الحفلة التي كنا
ننتظرها لتظهر لك ما هو
رائع في علاقتك مع الترس
هو أنه عندما تتغير حياتك أن يكون لديك
شخص ما لفهم ما هو
الشعور الذي كنت مريضًا جدًا في
التحضير له  تغيرت الحياة
وحدث هذا الحفل ، حدث CFDA
، حيث ظهر البرنامج التلفزيوني ، فلن تكون
هنا إذا لم يكن لديك ذلك في نفسك ،
افعل هذا ، لقد أذهلتني تمامًا
بعد فترة وجيزة من مرض أمي ،
كل شيء سار على النحو الذي أحب
أن أكون قادرًا عليه  لجعل النساء يشعرن
بالرضا وحقيقة أن أهم امرأة
في حياتي شعرت بالسوء كان من الصعب جدًا
بالنسبة لي ، وكنت غاضبًا من
الجميع وأعتقد أن العرض بدا
كما لو كان ، لكنني فخورة بهذا
العرض  أبيض وأسود للغاية ،
لقد كان هيكلًا نظيفًا للغاية ،
وأعتقد أن هذا العرض في فبراير
لم تكن الملابس أفضل من أي وقت مضى إذا تمكنت
من العثور على بطانة فضية بخلاف
حقيقة أن أمي تتحسن ، فقد
كان ذلك أول عرض في حياتي  أنهم
لم يتحدثوا أبدًا عن الفتيات اللواتي يدورن
والحفل الذي تحدثن فيه عن
بناء الملابس التي
استعصت علي ، أعتقد أن الملابس هي
وسيلة للهجوم في اليوم الذي كنت فيه دائمًا
منجذبًا حقًا للنساء إلى الأشخاص
عبر التاريخ الذين لديهم  استخدم
الملابس كطريقة لتذكر
أنك ارتديت تلك التنورة التي ارتديتها تلك القبعة
التي ارتديتها على تلك السترة
ويتذكر العالم أن هذه الصورة لك هي
حقًا ما تتمتع الملابس بالقدرة
على القيام به لتتمكن من إعطاء ذلك لشخص
ما  مرح